who here uses Postgres kind of show
hands a whole lot of folks okay I wasn't
sure if we had any mice equal users or
anyone anything else so so we're here
for a lot of the same reasons we
recognize that Postgres has a lot of
really great things that are going on
for it in the community native JSON
support native hash support there's a
lot of great community standards for
data integrity and insurance continued
excellence and a lot of really large and
really expensive sub queries and a lot
of numerous native extensions and
extensions supported by the community
with standards built in natively so
we're all here for the same reasons but
post Creston got even better as a
performant database so some of the
things I'm going to talk about today are
native table partitioning hash index
resiliency a big one for a lot of folks
which is full text index searching on
JSON and JSON blobs that is native now
and a big one that I'll probably talk
about which will be a little more in
depth parallel queries and how they
affect large joins indexes and other
portions of the code base and query
analyzer accuracy and changes to how the
query planner does efficient work as
well so you'll hear me talk about some
phrases that you'll probably sound
familiar if you're avid user of Postgres
but I'm not going to jump into in depth
how much they work so I'm not going to
go into how much bloat or vacuum
sequential scans or replications are
working as well as pruning and
statistics these are also changes that
happened in Postgres 10 but I'm not
going to cover them in this talk but a
little bit about me first
I joined Heroku a little over a year and
a half ago
I've been primarily working on Sinatra
and Ruby on Rails applications for the
better part of the last four years
primarily right now in my role I'm
focused on Postgres and high
availability modes and large data growth
so growth in the terabytes of data I've
worked on a lot of different data
service engines more than I can list I'm
not going to go through all them all
there that's
much time but on the side I'm trying to
be a lot more positive so I'm trying to
do a lot of self-help and life coaching
things so I'm trying to focus on a lot
of inspirational things so on the side I
do some super-secret project work on
this social interest platform because I
like Facebook but there's a lot of
negativity on there so some of the
things that I I'm looking for some basic
things that any social interest platform
would provide which is profiles but I'm
also looking for curated content so
inspirational quotes TV characters
movies TV shows foods the list goes on
and I'm imagining a lot of usage so
we're gonna just jump right into it and
the first thing that I'm going to talk
about is inspirational quotes and this
is one that I actually saw when I was
traveling to New Zealand which I thought
was fantastic which is happiness is not
a destination it's a way of life and I'm
hoping to see millions of these populate
throughout the the codebase and through
the platform but wow that that grew fast
so even though quotes aren't very big
they're just you know small string text
most databases even at large scale have
significant amount of RAM tons of disk
space but some usage scenarios that most
quotes are never updated or revisited
after a week and most people only want
the most recent and up-to-date quotes
they don't want to see stale stuff so
that's kind of tough that one table grew
really quickly some quick math there and
that's way more memory than I have so a
little bit about how Postgres and some
of its caching system are gonna work
here it's gonna attempt to load as much
stuff in memory as possible and then
it's going to try to use what it has in
memory and if there's overflow it'll
start doing disk writing with pointers
to the files and it'll open them up at
one at a time as it does file writing so
it actually will manipulate the disks a
lot more so caching is done this way
because if you access the data obviously
you're probably going to need it sooner
than later so it's going to try to do
that in a couple different ways but the
other problem with this is that temp
disk space is not free I I know we'd all
like to
it is but it's actually not there are a
lot of other overhead costs because
usually temp this space also happens
with where the data is stored on the
database on disk and caching records in
large quantities can have some
significant impacts especially as you're
trying to concurrently access the same
table multiple times with large data
sets so one of the real issues and this
is something that some people might have
seen in the past is that we can easily
stop connecting to the database entirely
if we run too many of these simultaneous
really heavy bloating or locking queries
so who likes fast queries everyone I'm
hoping everyone likes fast queries and
database is staying up and continuing to
connect yes yes big big thumbs up in the
front row thank you so a great thing
that they actually added as Postgres 10
is native table partitioning there's
been extensions in the community for a
while that do this but let's go into
some of the big wins on native
partitioning so native partitioning
actually can entirely avoid the back
vacuum and bloating process so bulk
loads and deletes and offloads can
happen without causing overhead to your
Postgres internals so slow accesses to
your database connections things like
that they're gonna be a lot less costly
because you're not stressing that one
giant table as much our most common used
rows are only going to be the sections
of the partitions we care about and a
lot of the seldom used data can stay
where it needs to on slow disk storage
or even off on like you know cold
storage we can move it off entirely and
one of the great things about this is
that query performance improve
dramatically we we got a lot more bang
for our buck when we actually do the
lookups previously we'd have to do best
effort random index scans and then
random access reads to the disks with
large data like this disk data storage
is kind of fragmented in some scenarios
and so in average of worst case
scenarios if you actually do
complexity some of these cases actually
end up being worse than sequential scans
so native partitioning is a great way to
optimize for this another key note to
have here is PG part man is still in ten
it's still supported but it doesn't have
some of the parallel support that we're
going to talk about a little later in
this talk some other small noteworthy
items for native partitioning it's not
natively supported in boram's
obviously you saw me writing raw sequel
in the migration script there are have
been gems to try to make this more
consistent in things like active record
but none of them are really well
supported right now a lot of another
great thing about this though is tables
can be created from your partitions so
if you need to do what I'd like to call
yomo tables your your month tables this
is or even week tables this is something
that you could absolutely do and this is
a great way to even segment even data
even further as it migrates through and
it's an easy way to understand your data
over long periods of time and you can
even create partitions from your
partitions I would add a partition mean
but I feel like they're overkill but so
now we want to do a pivot so we've had a
lot of use of the platform and people
are starting to create products and now
we want to do home delivery so how do we
get that done well we obviously need
customer addresses so this seems pretty
simple and we want you know a mobile app
to be able to access lots of different
customer addresses when they're you know
going making deliveries right we want to
take customer service seriously but we
do have a lot of customers and we have a
lot of addresses so addresses aren't
uniform across North America actually
they're very different even between the
US and Canada and even between different
states different states have different
rules and regulations about where
delivery drivers can stop and and other
really important features and gotchas
like that so nobody gets ticketed on the
street so there might be some important
instructions we also need for not just
customer satisfaction but for driver
notices as well so we can kind of store
this unstructured data already in
Postgres right each store already exists
today a lot of people I'm sure use it
it's not new it's a key-value store but
you know implementing it seems
straightforward enough let's just add
the hash right yeah man those interests
address lookups are real slow real slow
the other problem here is that when
somebody is trying to make an update to
this our drivers aren't going to get it
in real time it's not gonna happen
we could add an index to improve lookups
though so let's let's try that and let's
see what happens so let's let's add a
hash index on usage and hope for the
best right it seems like it should work
maybe maybe things improved but ooh show
hands anyone seen this error message
before show hands who uses hash indexes
in here not many people ok well that's
that's good to know
um so probably a lot of people know for
good reason that hash indexes aren't
really well supported in Postgres 9x for
a lot of different reasons but the key
one being replication is is not
supported so it's not treated as a
first-class citizen the the other one is
you get a lot of misleading failures
like that that kind of looked like a
data corruption issue but actually
that's an index corruption and that's
because the hash index can't keep up so
there other things about this is that if
we have extremely large datasets to pull
from sometimes you have to completely
ask that the hash index and rebuild it
from scratch which is not a great
experience what's the solution if we
can't rely on this hashing mechanism if
we really want to use H store since it's
mostly supported well Postgres 10
actually finally brought it into the
light and made it a first-class citizen
so it added first-class citizen support
such as replication it made it crash
safe through shutdowns and fail overs
replication is done faster lookup so the
growth of each page for that index are
actually consistent with regular
indexing
this is and the pruning happens much
more consistently as well so indexes
don't go as stale as often so going back
to this we can rely on this much more
consistently and and have better peace
of mind and we do see actual improvement
now checking through and updating the
hash itself the the biggest thing that
I'd like to point out here is the
locking concurrency issue was a huge
problem and we use H store at Heroku for
a lot of different use cases the the
reduced locking for concurrent access
for records is a big win for us even
though we don't use a lot of hash index
as H store in general for the few places
that we do that this is a really big
important thing for us so going
backwards we're talking about more
curated content on on my social media
platform and I want to talk about you
know movies and TV shows and characters
that we love that we can't get enough of
for any big nerds out there I'm a huge
flash fan I met John Wesley Shipp for
the first time earlier this year which
was fantastic so I want to list all
these movies and TV shows and I want to
get the characters for all of them so
each show can have potentially fifty
hundreds maybe even thousands of
characters if anyone watches Game of
Thrones I'm sure everyone's excited
so each record can have a lot of varying
data over time right and some things
we'll want to try to you know watch is
genres catchphrases you know famous
accessories and items or even just you
know certain ways that they dress or
look or interact with other characters
I'm sure some people are gonna get a
little schwifty after all of rails cough
so we need some way to keep that data
unstructured but co-located with the
general structure of how we want to
address media and characters in general
so let's let's use a JSON blob because
this seems to make sense for this
scenario we can query third-party data
sources and we can get them in
consistent JSON format so we can reparse
them over and over again and we can get
update
the great thing about this is that we do
have this flexibility but it opens as us
opens us up to a lot of other gotchas
one of which is each row is dynamically
sized because of this so it's not
consistent what size each record is and
because we can have so many different
data sources analyzing each character
each record this could potentially get a
little hairy in tracking how this
information changes over time so how can
we keep this unstructured and not have
to parse it all or create constant
relationships through this so we could
create multiple tables we we could add a
lot of one-to-many relationships we
could modify our rails app entirely to
manage this information we could even do
partitioning based on some subset of
where the data is colligative per show
but as much as we could do all those
things there is some other easier item
to do and that is using the full text
index searching that's been added in
Postgres 10 so because we can store
whole request bodies we can store
custom-made JSON blobs this allows us
for a lot of more no sequel dynamic
schema operations and this is what we're
really caring about especially when
we're trying to get this off the ground
in initial stages this adds a lot of
flexibility so one of the great things
here is that there's a lot of examples
of how to do this online now on the pus
crocin materials but this keeps our data
structure on unstructured and flexible
so the big thing about this is indexes
can actually filter on a lot of
different views and kind of perspectives
that you want to do for the type of
index searches you want to do on your
JSON since they are treated as
first-class citizens as well and the
other great thing about this is this
gives us ways to you know target folks
on the platform that we're looking at if
we want to target them for you know
being big Marvel fans or you know maybe
somebody can't get enough of you know
Joey from France
maybe he just wants to say how you doing
all the time
but I'm a big fan of Thor so a lot of
hammers for me but let's let's jump back
for a sec quotes was our big takeoff
item that was the big one that got the
platform recognized and people love
throwback Thursday so let's let's create
a throwback stream of quotes for for
folks who want to know on this day my
favorite posters posted these quotes so
we want to be able to replay a stream of
old quotes right well streams should
include all of the posters that I liked
and followed not just my own posts so
that's a lot more quotes than you would
normally see and even getting one month
of posts and that's a lot of queries
especially if you're following a few
hundred other people that's a lot of a
lot of quotes especially for power
posters who post multiple times a day so
yeah here we go so Postgres 10 did a lot
of things to optimize how we do these
types of queries and how fast they come
back so we're gonna I'm gonna touch on
three there are more optimizations in
the parallel areas on how to return
queries that Postgres 10 did I'm only
gonna touch on these three because these
three are usually the big ones that
people talk about so we're gonna talk
about parallel bitmap heat scans gather
merges and merge joints so let's jump
into it so in 96 parallel searching and
scanning was was introduced it was a
little limited though so it used to only
do sequential scans and sequential scans
were only done the primary tables so
this kind of created the problem where
you couldn't rely on indexes you we had
a little bit of a trade-off here where
you either had to rely on your table
caching to be really effective or your
indexes to be really good but you
couldn't get an overlap here which was
kind of painful the big thing about
Postgres 10 is that changed when they
added way more parallelization to every
level of your
table schemes including indexes so you
can it do parallel searching through
your indexes first you actually go
through and construct the only the index
files first so that you are much more
methodical and strategic on how you do
your queries and how the results are
loaded and so this requires a lot less
data loaded upfront a lot less caching
and way less results that student to
parse through and a whole lot less disk
reads so the next one we're going to
talk about is gather and gather is
actually the mechanism in which Postgres
introduced how to do parallel query
construction and and result retrieval so
it was introduced with the idea of
workers obviously to do asynchronous
processing and the big thing here was
that there were multiple layers on how
results were returned a lot of the time
they were returned in arbitrary fashions
mostly in the order to have how fast
they returned from each worker so
unfortunately if you're adding searches
or sorts to this portion of the
mechanism this is going to add a
significant amount of overhead because
you're requiring not just the search of
the b-tree but you're also requiring an
extra order layer to happen after the
initial result sets are retrieved so a
small example here is you know I have a
bunch of IDs in my be tree and I just
want to retrieve the primes right so
here's a small example of a be tree the
the issue here is that when when we're
going through and checking through
Prime's the leaf nodes in some scenarios
have more content than either the roots
or some other leaf nodes so certainly if
nodes a will turn faster than others the
root node is our first return response
so 17 was actually the first node I'll
go back here so 17 was the the first one
we actually saw on the left side if
you'll actually look on the three leaf
nodes to the left of 17 Elevens only got
one so our first records are going to be
17 19 and 11 depending
on how fast they return then to so we
actually get stuff out of order so
another pass is going to be required to
sort through the somewhat strange return
results of the workers themselves and so
they were only trained to be returned as
fast as possible with no context
well this changed in Postgres 10 so
Postgres 10 changed this by optimizing
the worker collection results so gather
merges actually sped up the parallel
worker result retrieval because they
also kept context of where they
encountered the data that they actually
cared about and they kept them into
account as the result sets were returned
so it removed a lot of overhead for
sorting after the fact because at the
end it ended up being mostly just a flat
line so this was really beneficial
especially for really large datasets
traversing huge tables so kind of
revisiting this we can see that we have
a whole nother side of the beach way we
didn't touched right I I kind of glossed
over it but for good reason because
really when we parsed it down we
actually held context it did actually
move through the B tree and and
construct how we thought we were going
to see everything the reason we kept
context here is because we kept context
of the locations that we visited each
node at and so this is much more natural
ordering of operations from an intuitive
mental standpoint so it's easier to
mental map how our data is retrieved as
well too so the great thing is is
because as we merge the leaves and the
roots we basically can turn this into a
linked list and it becomes a simplified
array that's mostly natively ordered
even before we add other order clauses
if you add the order clauses they're
kept in context along with the parallel
workers so they know what to do when
they're ordering as they return results
and then the last one we're gonna cover
here is merge joints and this one while
maybe performance wise doesn't always
pack the most wallet is the most one of
the
one's for me as well so kind of applying
this to checking all the other posters I
care about for throwback Thursday I need
to join on the other customers quotes
right so previously nine six only
allowed this on nested and sub-query
loops or or hash joins the this didn't
always happen on on the primary query of
the table so a lot of our sub queries
were optimized for this but not
necessarily the originating one that we
cared about so this adds a lot of
overhead and even though indexing and
ordering is great it could actually make
things worse and not better especially
the indexing portion which is surprising
sometimes but it can be a gotcha so
parallel merge join was added to
consistently parallel do parallel
operations for all the merges at all
levels so all the sub queries all the
way up the stack from from each sub
table or even tables you've had to
rejoin to get different data sets for
temporary tables for example are now
going to be done in parallel as well so
this is gonna make things much more
efficient outer sides of the joins
especially when we do no comparisons or
checks like that are gonna be the most
effective because we're not going to be
as restrictive here and it's going to be
much quicker to run through certain
sections of that with less data and
combined with a lot of the parallel
changes to the indexes gonna be way
faster and getting all of the data that
you care about again the parallel
changes that also happen to gather merge
will give you some natural ordering by
default even before you specify order
but will still maintain context for
adding order as well so the last thing
I'm gonna touch on which I did mention
this is a real-world example actually
from something that we track at Heroku
which is part of tracking our issues on
our internal repos and external repos as
well so that we have a good list of
items for when we get future requests
issues bugs things like that and that is
actually even though this table is
pruned pretty consistently for the
issues
mapping the github issue to a repo ID
it's not huge but it's not tiny either
here is the query an analyzer for for
the table for a given repo ID execution
times not great this index is basically
not being used even though we expect it
to be used in 96 it definitely didn't
get used at all and so we end up doing
sequential scanning through it and it
gives us some pretty crappy runtimes
here's the great thing with all the
changes we post grows 10 the parallel
index got figured out by the query
analyzer and it's neat being used now
even on a tiny table
that's ridiculous just gonna let that
sink in for a sec that that's a half a
gig table that's not even a big table
that's a tiny one the changes that have
occurred in the performance games are
huge I'm not going to go through query
analytics that's another talk in and of
its own that is way too much time for
what we have to get through today so
unfortunately that's if you want to hear
me talk more about it or explain
anything more that I've seen in my last
year and a half two years come talk to
me after but there are a few last-minute
gotchas with Postgres 10 with rails that
i want to go through when i touched on
some of them but maybe someone you might
not know rails 4 doesn't support
Postgres 10
unfortunately they can the connection
protocols changed and how Postgres 10
works and so unfortunately post rails 4
only supports up to Postgres 9 6 if you
want to make the move to 10 you will
have to be on rails 5 again as I've
stated before partitioning is not native
to the Ruby and Ruby on Rails ORM
so our specific index types like hash
indexes and JSON indexes for the full
text query index searching we went over
today and the analytics queries are all
not available
except for in Ross sequel as well so
some things to know but that's one of
the reasons I love working at Heroku is
because we try to offer a lot of tools
for stuff like this so with the release
of Postgres 10 and the support for that
we've added a lot of extra support and
numerous extensions to support posters
10 as well we've added managed Postgres
credentials because the permission
schemes are very confusing as we've
found over the years new updated
hardware plans at the same price points
improved CLI analytics because our
analytics Eli's use the same query
analyzer that they do there and the same
PG internals that have had the
optimizations done as well and we are
beta beta a new feature right now for
those to test out called Postgres
connection pooling so the posters
Postgres extensions that we offer are
you know numerous and most of them are
natively offered we offer a few external
ones like post chips and things like
that if you want the complete list go go
check them out but the big one that I
love here is the is the time travel one
that's that's a big favorite especially
with the new changes to partition
Postgres manage credentials was
something we actually released late last
year but we did this for a lot of
different reasons we had a lot of
customer asks for this so Postgres
permissions are really difficult to
reason about their add a lot of
different layers and they have a lot of
nuance into creating granularity
understanding revoking permissions
things like that we still allow
customization when we issue manage
credentials but we've tried to take a
lot of the guesswork out of initially
creating a lot of these credentials and
roles for tables so we try to consider
things like special tables or special
characters that no one likes sequel
objection Bobbi tables can can stay at
home with his mom name lengths are
another big gotcha there's actually
certain character limits that if you
blow them
Postgres silently doesn't tell you so
that's that's another strange one and
we've also published some of the best
practices as well so if you want to see
some of the other things you can check
them out
the Postgres credentials deaf center but
I encourage everyone to even if you're
not using managed credentials consider
things like separations of concern
principle of least privilege and even
better external control access if you're
using a third party vendor that needs
data access you you want to give them
very restricted things you don't want to
give them access to PII data for example
to some of the things you insure for
your customers so the other big one that
we did earlier this year was broken PGX
plans I was directly actually part of
this project which was fantastic I was
very happy and excited about this which
was we were able to utilize the the
latest hardware virtualization for
better i/o better CPU and query
optimization and also we've added all
these plans under dedicated hardware so
that you get consistent and stable
performance we've documented about it in
the blog post but the big wins here are
that we've doubled CPU cores at tiers
four and up we're exposing some of the
dedicated provision iOS for plans and
we're increasing data disk size at every
tier and prices either stayed the same
or lowered so please go check that out
if you're interested in checking out
some performance on the hardware side
the one that I we do for a long time is
one that I use on a daily basis
especially when people file support
tickets for us is the Heroku CLI
especially for Postgres we've used PG
diagnose and this is something that has
been out there for a while but I want to
reiterate because Postgres database
tuning has been a big deal and other
people have talked about it at the
conference we've we've had a deaf Center
out there for a long time and we have
the extension CLI to add on to the
native Heroku PG CLI commands so the big
one is PG diagnose but if you're looking
at sequential scans or caching and hit
rates some of the things that I might
have talked about today we actually
offer pre predefined ways of querying
that information through all your tables
and schemas so please go check that out
as well
now the one that I I know a lot of
people have heard about a lot of
companies have started using
bouncer so PG bouncer for those who are
familiar or not have added management
for post crest connection pooling this
is basically because there's not really
this idea built into Postgres so
connection pooling is done outside of
Postgres and this kind of adds
insurances to making sure connections
don't stay open longer than they're
supposed to be queries don't kill your
database and we've added this as part of
the connection pooling that's how this
is done
PG bouncer is is in beta as Roku PG
connection pooling so why use it well
one thing Roku in general loves to see
is stats we love our stats this is
better visibility into seeing how our
connections behave this also gives a lot
of guardrails to protect your database
and keep it up especially if you have
multiple applications connecting to a
single database and this is really great
for asynchronous workloads for anyone
using lots of active job or anything
like that this is fantastic we've
offered it as a beta we're still working
out making the best practices out there
we're still trying to get some some
feedback from folks who you know ask for
more customers ability or better use
case scenarios so we're still doing some
some public beta work on it right now
it is supported out there and it is well
document it so though if you're
interested in using what's on server
right there for pg connection pooling
please go check it out we still offer a
client-side build pack that can run on a
dyno it doesn't have as many of the
built-in features that we'll be adding
to Postgres connection pooling but if
you are interested in using it separate
from the database itself on your
application layers or something like
that it's still available out there whoo
and that is it what a marathon thank you
so much please come check out the booth
I'm the last presenter for Heroku today
and as always thank you again so much
for letting me come and talk to you at
railsconf
[Applause]